hello and welcome to this video yeah in
case you looked at the last couple of
years there's a rating drop I lost
against a think ochita and I did not
upload this video very sick of this
stuff and yeah anyway let's focus focus
on that game
it's a funny opening it's a really funny
opening night at 3 f5 and yeah this is
some this is an interesting set up here
with with g6e 5 and c5 black is just
very ambitious in the center but yeah it
looks why shouldn't it work let's let's
say it let's put it like that
while it's not going to play d4 anytime
soon and I have a space advantage I
never really believed to be honest in
that d3 move I mean I see the idea of
course with E for it never fell to me
that there should be something
substantial
okay is trading like no tomorrow here
that must be pretty comfortable for
black yeah I'm just playing
very simple moves what is the idea
cancels rookie aid I can try to yeah I
expected him to do that yeah I don't
really want to trade I'm thinking look
f6 g6 maybe
just prevent 95 so night before he felt
was a problem I can't even play a
foreign disposition 94 also it is
actually making quite some sense if he
takes politics how is he castling
okay
this is probably probably right even
though you might have 95 and no no I can
take actually take and then I'm no
weekend doesn't have 95 at the NC 2 is
dropping then this move is probably
quite good 94 84 his check
check so some some queen III would be
cool for meat or some some check on the
dark squares but there is known right
away okay taking is the most obvious
move is there anything better look for
no doesn't it doesn't make much sense if
I go if I go g5 is going Queen G dream
okay King c1 does not help him
I have Queen - a - but
Drago Queen a Jew anyway I don't know I
shouldn't spend too much time trying to
refute it and then losing one time again
like I did a million times before there
would be one but what else be three I
take the pawn I mean he has to play
rugby one
then I wanted to play 25 that was the
idea am I missing something after Luke
b1 which is super obvious that it should
be the only move I'm missing something
okay so why is that even a consideration
I mean I don't get it
check
[Music]
there's no technical way to win
maybe I can take here takes and check
and Quincy one check queen or queen f1
actually Queen f1 time warning
rookie to Quincy to
yeah just checks reading is probably
good enough white resides that was a bit
weird I thought that should be even
better and then it was actually maybe
why I played this very unambitious Lee I
don't know what's best against if I die
think black should be should be okay and
yeah this is looking quite chanyeol
didn't want to trade ever think this
wasn't okay also difficult now I have a
white it's interesting that the engine
wants to take and now here you know okay
it's more comfortable it's more
comfortable from black but now I just
know it chest gets uglier dad sumo there
would be one is clearly the only move I
don't know what it what what happened
here I was thinking this twenty five
that was my idea
just put this on a worse Square engine
was gonna get six that makes sense yeah
blocking the way to e7 young child is he
for was stronger check but at least I
didn't spoil it completely okay guys
thanks for watching